good morning millennials
back to the toast happy Tuesday we are
kicking off toast friends and family
week here at the toast and we are
kicking it off with a personal favorite
not only because she's hilarious we
support women in comedy yada yada but
because she showed up in a T-shirt with
my face on it and it's like she knows
the way to my heart Ben is always saying
whenever we're talking about people he's
like oh I really like that person and
Ben's like you only like them because
they're like so flattering and like up
your ass like that is the way to my
heart so you showing up in one of my
merch available actually I think it's
sold out but toastmarch.com sold out but
I appreciate hyper respect is due I
really and I have to say this is good
merch only it's like Chanel it's
basically Chanel and yeah I give respect
and I just support other women in comedy
too okay so we have so much to catch up
on the last time we're on the toast I
feel like was a year ago because that
was Jackie's maternity leave and he was
born in like February it was a little
bit over a year ago and that was the
first time we met and it was magical it
was the first we made out
it was the first time we like talked
[__] yeah yeah no you stayed after the
toast for a while and we just like
gossiped but it was a really good gossip
oh my God thank you really good but it's
gotten me in trouble before so that's
what I'm hoping you'll do here today
yeah I'm a loose lip [__] not just
talking about my [__] and I but I I
just I can't lie it's a problem like
Paige and I were talking about oh I
already brought a page that's literally
Me and Jackie oh I do no I'm like Jackie
thinks that like and no and Jackie said
that no I'm so annoying I'm like I'm not
obsessed with her but Paige just told me
she liked my outfit today but that's
good but when we're in Ubers like I I'll
try to lie and then I'll get myself in
like a weird horrible situation where
Paige is like so good at being sleek and
smart that's so Paige yeah I'll be so
interested to see on Friday if Paige
talks about you as much as you talk
about her honestly we're gonna have to
tally it up because it could start a
fight yeah if she doesn't like honor you
in the way that you are honoring she
normally really does yeah no you guys
are like such good best friends but it's
also weird how compared to like the toes
just I feel like we're not sisters but
we have similar chemistry that you and
Jackie have yeah like I mean I'm so the
Claudia
Jack you saw the page not that we copied
you guys but like no no there was
inspiration that is what I seek to do
ever when I wake up every morning
Inspire others to be the worst version
of themselves and so seeing it in person
with you is really it's humbling but
that's why I like that we hit it off
because sometimes too Claudius could
like it could be too much too much air
taken up in the room but no you're right
we kind of we do Vibe and yeah to get an
ass back is like it's like I got a
little gold star well you know what I I
follow the data you know I was telling
you before I'm kind of like the eyes and
ears of the I.T Department here at the
toast and I'm constantly looking into
our analytics and I actually found it
really interesting when we had all these
guest co-hosts come for Jackie's
maternity leave who performed well and
who didn't you would think people with
like so many followers would perform
great and you and Paige as podcasters
yourselves because someone with a tiny
following like you no no no you guys are
podcasters it's so much easier to
podcasts you guys and you have an
audience so I looked I looked at the
data and the data said we want Hannah
back that's amazing well I also I think
chemistry is so important because I've
had those people you know who are so
famous and they don't really give you
you anything or you don't Vibe also it's
mental health let's have a good time
let's have a that's what we do here at
the toast we seek to inspire and to
radiate positivity also I'm very proud
of your Tick Tock because a year ago you
were just beginning your journey I
actually wasn't beginning my journey I
was just looked like I was beginning
because I had no followers and I um like
had the worst content but you had the
passion I will say our conversation and
a lot of the advice that you gave me
like really did inspire me and you were
just so smart about the whole thing
because you were like you know you make
such funny jokes on the podcast and on
your Instagram stories like reformulate
that for tick tock like it's okay yeah
and I definitely took and I'm still I'm
not doing great compared to you and
that's what I wanted to talk to you
about today
um but I I feel like you were definitely
a part of my very small success I I will
I see you as my protege I really
appreciate it but like you're all over
my fyp and I'm just like I'm yeah I'm
very proud of you oh yeah that's true
yeah I kind of did it in my head a lot
yeah okay that I totally could add to
the engagement that's my bad I apologize
for that well you know the last time you
were here we talked a lot about Tick
Tock and I was like you know happy but
mostly jealous that you had like had
success I remember you had like 600 000
followers I'm like oh my God I'm so
happy for you
um and now you're here and what do you
have two million
okay Tic Tac saved my life yeah well I
want to talk to you about that it truly
saved my life yeah because I'm like you
and that like I was put on this Earth to
express myself I want people I want to
say things that people are afraid to say
I want people to question things I'm I'm
look it's not that important I'm not
Mother Teresa but like it makes me feel
alive to be heard and when I was doing
reality TV
you know you only get seen in certain
ways and you have good Seasons you have
bad seasons and then once I was off the
show I was like I need to express myself
I love to create and Tick Tock allowed
me this like safe space where the
algorithm's so good that it finds other
girlies and gays who need who needs you
or who have the same you know common
sense of humor so like my followers are
so funny they're so smart they're so
good looking
um and it was a way for me to express
myself and you're having so much success
with it like how has it impacted just
I'm curious like from a business
perspective how like blowing up on Tick
Tock like that has impacted like the
other facets of your business like
burning in hell you host two podcasts
everyone knows giggly Squad burning in
hell
um how does that like filter into other
parts of your business great question
it's selling tickets for me really yeah
because I also so famously Emily
Ratajkowski just I just saw she just
gave me a shout out and my whole after
like reality TV I would imagine like
kind of a bad experience happening and
then as you're on the street everyone's
like what's going on with you and so and
so and it's like a breakup where
everyone's just asked public in the
public eye and asking you about your
breakout in the Public Square and I
remember thinking like I want to do
everything I can so that no one
remembers yeah that I didn't realize
what you're known for I don't want that
to be on my Tombstone yeah no and by the
way I don't even really associate you as
like a former Summer House cast member I
mean I I also am not one to be like [__]
that [__] it was such a part of my life
and it was so good a platform and during
that time when I was 26 and single it
was so fun
um but now for Emmy Ratajkowski she
called me um some comedian girl that's
huge I called my therapist I said we did
it we did it we did it Joe we're done we
did a Joe some comedian girl is how I
want to be known but it's funny because
the girls in their 30s a lot of them
like they've been following me for a
while from batches days
where then like I will get stopped on
the street by like a 17 year old girly
who's like Tick Tock so cool and I'll be
like that's this is inappropriate stuff
you're watching right but should be like
I like your Tick Tock and then I get a
big head yeah because if the Gen Z's
think I'm cool
I put like I'm done nobody understands
that better than me I've been chasing
the 17 year olds not in like a Dalai
Lama kind of way no in like a cool hip
kind of like you know Mentor kind of way
no like I will if a younger like high
school or college girl wants to talk to
me I am all ears I'm taking notes I'm
actually I'm asking her like is this
outfit okay right no that's like but the
Genesee girls are [__] cool I feel
like they really decenter men from their
life because they didn't grow up with
like the Disney movies yeah yeah like we
did and as two married women
I feel like we're both really good at
decentering men from our life despite
the fact that we're married where is Ben
uh he's in LA and I completely agree
with what you said but this is in
Ireland oh don't even know actually I
think out I think well for me it's like
I didn't like consciously de-center men
for my life I'm far too self-centered to
have anything other than maybe the
center of my life you know wow and
that's been really it's so self-aware
one thing about me like say what you
want about me you could say I'm annoying
yada for sure I agree but I am nothing
if not self-aware and I love that for
you and that's why you're so funny thank
you because you say it before everyone
calls you out on it and you're like I
got there first yep but that's I I do
think when you're making decisions based
on what other like to meet a man
somewhere what a man will think you get
off your alignment and then you'll start
attracting weird energies and like I'm
at Dez Des tell me in the background of
a comedian's Instagram story that was
that was crazy I know technology
not we've only been married less than a
year really last may we got married wow
that's so crazy it feels like just like
it's like you're just married and my
wedding has been overshadowed by
skandival which I'm dealing with that's
that's definitely tough I'm dealing with
um no one talks about my dress no one
talks about the flowers that's literally
disgusting um do you think if you had
been on summer house deal you would have
done like a TV wedding
like probably right
no we would not
my nana my grandma would have loved it
of course would have loved it the thing
with the TV wedding
um
it's
it's like you're you're wedding when
they air it could be shown in so
different so many different ways and
you'll see some weddings that are like
overshadowed by like a couple fighting
right or like I mean sheena's wedding
was iconic yeah the crop top I was
invited but I couldn't go but her first
wedding you were at no oh yeah no I'm a
fan I'm a full fan girl I can't believe
you were invited to the Brock wedding
why didn't you go
Paige and I had shows [__] I know
[__] page [__] page with like
she's just she makes me work so much
she's always texting me bothering me um
wait okay so what
wait what was I going to say oh so your
Tick Tock you find that like the the
success you've had on Tick Tock filters
its way positively into like your ticket
sales Tick Tock is like my own TV show
and it's as like I was a comedy video
producer before I went on summer house
where I love to write scripts I love to
you know I just love to think of an idea
and then it becomes something physical
you get it yeah so I wake up and instead
of being like man I'm not on TV anymore
I'm like what can I post on my channel
that people are gonna see and it's
everything from my podcast to stand up
Clips to the man on the street which are
so good thank you I see them ripped off
and like people using slime next to it
you know like the Duets someone like
rubbing slime and then is that good or
bad it's good that means you [__]
made it [__] like that although they
get like hundreds of millions of views
that like don't count towards you no I
know
I am you are but I've heard drama about
it what have you heard one guy told me
that if you're in the tick tock Creator
fun they suppress your views they
suppress your views I haven't
experienced that okay but who knows
there might be a point now if you're
willing to share like what are you
making per month on on Tick Tock Creator
fund good question it's not like
Millions no it's like it's a pretty bad
conversion no I think I'm making like
like maybe five or six though wow that's
pretty good no I don't know enough to
like pay more than rent like I could
live my life off Tick Tock wow that's so
interesting and I don't know if that's
for sure it could be 3 000 right I'm
sure it's different every month based on
your views exactly I'd say two to five
thousand hmm just throwing numbers
around I also like to do this thing
where I don't check and then one day I
check and I'm like am I rich
yes I'm very bad with finances cruel
interest I do it for the art but I
definitely do it for the money but I
I've been told by psychic that I that
money will always follow me but if I do
my passion yeah so I'm one of those
where like I'm like a troubled artist
who just like happens to get a deal it
just kind of sounds like the psychic was
telling you what you wanted to hear it's
like yeah pursue your art money will
find you like that's not how art works
you know well that's why after college I
went into cold calling sales did you
yeah I was okay I'm good at that you
know I actually was
I take that back you're very personable
all apparently all I would do was giggle
on the phone like I would just try to
make people laugh and the guys I worked
with on the sales team were like she
just like laughs the whole time but
people I guess they kind of trusted me
but I hated taking what are you selling
I was selling digital marketing services
oh so you were working for jincha yes
old people homes right and I was like
can you read this contract no sign up
sign on the dotted line by the way I do
have to say with the Bravo universe
what gen Shaw did was so horrible but
people will get treated so much worse
for so much less and there's no
inflation it's Chris Rock The Selective
outrage pisses me off so much because
you don't know what the momentum is
gonna do Jackie and I are always talking
about that it's like yeah we eat this up
but like we are losing sight of reality
like Jen shot
exploited our most vulnerable think of
your grandma Yeah she intentionally
exploited the most vulnerable members of
all of our communities like the old the
elderly the disabled like it's so
disgusting and we're all just like
eating it up like like there's really no
and this should shouldn't come as a
surprise to anyone but there's no
morality in in reality TV and I think
that's something as you get older I've
been watching reality TV for like 10
years it starts to bother you when you
get older it's like what am I watching
yeah and I do think it's like watching a
train wreck and I always said if I was
on TV and I did something crazy that
made someone feel more sane about their
life the night's in my job yeah that's
just the that's the job that's the job
and it's you times a thousand but yeah I
just think selective outrage is a thing
yeah and next time you're like gonna
like freak out at someone over like
something they said in a confessional
like just think of Jen Shaw no and I
will say I'm really happy for you
because I've always really liked you and
the last time we had you on the toast
everyone was so excited and there was
people who were like oh she was the
worst on somewhere else and now when we
um announced that you were coming on
like people were like yes love giggly
Squad burning and how I love her
toothpaste I gotta go see her comedy
like you've really come out of that I
think probably one of the best I think I
said this on maybe a patreon episode
recently like it's really um it could be
an example to other reality stars I
think you really have done such a good
job thank you so much I mean I actually
just met stassi like I had a full
podcast with her the other week and I
told her like you know she's obviously
had so many ups and downs and it's
really easy to quit yeah it's really
easy to give up on yourself and it's
really easy to just wallow
um but I guess the advice I've learned
from like having hard times and stuff is
like
I take it as a message from the universe
which is like we're shifting you know
and I the universe is aggressive with me
we're shifting like some people you know
how like something subtle will happen
for like 10 years and then you're like
wait I hate this man or like I hate this
job I will like things will just blow up
immediately where the universe does not
want any confusion for me no warnings no
warnings and you know what you need to
do so I just like list I love failing
and I fail all the time but I'm like I
never take it personally and I use it
like okay you [__] up or this was not
right for you we're on to the next we're
on to the next yeah and you just have to
keep swimming like Dory that's like my
favorite Taylor Swift lyric it's
actually a newer lyric so it's maybe not
my favorite but it's one that really
resonated me with me it's um no one sees
if you lose when you're playing
Solitaire it's like if you're only
competing with yourself
failure is just a part of life it's not
like this big embarrassing thing like
you're only looking like horse blinders
is that okay I'm gonna cry I love
getting into mental health moments this
is a sports reference and my grandpa was
like a basketball coach it's very
Brooklyn never let the fear of striking
out but I feel like you would understand
basketball references they said even
when it's raining the hoop is always
there yeah so like you can't see it all
the time and I realize so much of life
is the story you tell in your head like
I could have sat there and told myself
all these things of what I think people
think of me but like actually Taylor
Striker called it she said I have bde as
in Big delusional energy oh my God okay
so the introduction of my book which I
know you read is so good Fantastical
delusions like just about how being
delusional is such an important part of
confidence and an important part of like
chasing your dreams and I mean like
delusional like with your own self yeah
no not don't be delusional like in
reality yeah that's nobody likes people
like that you're like the sky is green
like your sense of self and your
confidence should have an ounce of
delusion yeah and I ultimately believe
that you cannot hit any goal that you
can't imagine for yourself and also
you're not to like eight be like talking
about your age no I'm saying you're a
baby oh my God you're a baby and you've
accomplished okay we're just sucking
each other's dicks right now but the
best it's like audio porn
um you've done and accomplished so many
things like written a book are you
kidding me so like you fit all these
things in but that was all you imagining
it like if you guys if you don't think
it it's not gonna happen the world
doesn't just plop book deals but they do
for some people sometimes and I think
something that you and I have in common
which is why I think we're like always
gassing each other up is because like
we've had things you know opportunities
taken away from us we've had like you
know cancellations and so that's like it
feels even more more accomplishing when
you get a book deal or when you sell out
a theater because you really had to do
all that [__] on your own and even you
know rebuild from Ground Zero more than
one time for sure it feels even better
and also we've had ego deaths yeah of
course we love an ego death and that's
why I think we're funny because it's
like we know what it's like to be really
dark and feel like the biggest piece of
[__] and then be like where do we go
from here yeah what's next what's next
what I mean the Madonna's of the comedy
World some would say we're Reinventing
we're growing we are learning world you
know know if she wanted to ask you
because you're like such a stand-up
comic and you are always like whenever I
watch all like all your Instagram
stories it's just like more shows more
shows more shows and I do comedy like in
a way that I think is very bizarre to a
lot of people like I take like a full
year off and then I'll do a whole year
on year off year on and that's just how
I can realistically like integrate it
into my life but you are just all the
time 24 7 and I was just I did this
event with Nikki Glaser and she was like
literally I am gone every single week 52
weeks out of the year and it's like this
road life and that's so tough and you're
married and so you're married to another
comedian who lives the same lifestyle
when do you guys like [__]
like what are you guys ever in the same
bed okay my biggest advice with marriage
is like don't see each other oh that's
actually so funny you know like when
people become your roommate like we've
never we haven't gotten to that it's not
texting it's not sexy but you're so
right I'm living this kind of
untraditional life where I actually I
met my husband he had an apartment in
the Lower East Side the woman passed
away next door wasn't me we don't know
how it happened rip and I got the
apartment next door so we have two
apartments next to each other I
technically have my own apartment like
my own space do you have a podcast
studio in there I wanted to but it was a
little too echoing oh yeah and I didn't
want to mix you know work and pleasure
as in like where I nap all the time 100
but I do think
traveling because we have the same gig
like I'll finish a show and I'll call
him and he'll be like yeah I just got
off stage how was it
um and this is all we know when you meet
people later in life you're kind of two
complete people and you see if the
puzzle pieces fit or I think when you
meet younger you can grow together and
evolve into whatever or that's what I
always say because people like you got
married so young and I used to like
resent people saying that yeah but the
older I get it's actually so true and
it's you really can meet someone when
you're really young and be so in love
and then just like I'm so different now
than I was when I met that I was 18. it
was literally 10 years ago yeah oh my
God and thank God that like we both grew
into people who we like yes but I could
totally see me becoming someone who Ben
wasn't interested in anymore and so I
actually I do now understand why people
were like wow that's so young are you
sure you don't want to wait like no [__]
off [__] I want to get married like
yeah and I think all the cool girls are
doing it do you think in your third well
now weddings are a little chooky but
that's besides the point it's because
gen Z's can't get married
but I do think because we met dating in
your 30s is hard because you have your
routines you have your rituals like when
a guy comes it gets confusing and you
don't want to lose yourself so I happen
to find someone who Lifestyles do work
together and
it's it's been really fun I also think
with stand up
when I started to do stand up I had I
had dated a stand-up comedian and he had
kind of like showed me the ropes before
I knew I wanted to do it but I fell in
love with the fact I'm like you could do
podcasts all day and then just perform
at night and then like audition and you
could just live a creative life I don't
have to call cold call sales people what
am I doing right so when I started stand
up I had a bunch of like real stand-up
comics of the New York scene pulled me
aside and they were like if you want to
do it you got to do it right you gotta
get on stage all the time but what's
beautiful is the reason
women there's not more female stand-ups
is because that old school stand-up
lifestyle is not conducive for women no
do you want to go to midnight to best
die to be at a bar full of drunk men
doing jokes about your period no end if
you have kids that's the other it's
certainly not conducive to moms it's not
conducive so it it's this old school
life but the internet such as Tick Tock
podcasts meme pages that are so female
like voiced and you don't know who's
writing it but it's the women or the
gays and that has enabled people like
you to be in stand up and it's super
powerful so I've I've kind of evolved to
be more like you were
I I have multiple things going on and
I'm not just doing one thing stand up 16
spots a week I do when I can but I am
traveling a lot and I'm I'm making
stand-up is evolving and Tick Tock is a
huge reason yeah and so I thank you Tick
Tock it again
I'm jealous for you but I'm telling you
just keep going because I know you are
so and I will say like probably my my
most like my best performing content is
our podcast clips and so why I asked you
so good why I asked like where you see
the value and where you see Tick Tock
making good impacts is because for us
like it has blown up the podcast like
our podcast numbers are that's amazing
and so many people like when I do meet
and greets and stuff they're like oh I
found you on Tick Tock I'm like yo shut
up your Clips are so good we work really
hard on them thank you they're really
good and I do think
um like giggly Squad we just started
posting them now because we used to just
film on Zoom I know and my friends are
like are you just traveling a lot and
I'm like we're both in Manhattan but
she's in Midtown which is like Europe
yeah that's tough and we'll be like do
you want to get together and she's like
no no but see that's what we're always
talking about how weird it is how like
podcasting is an audio first platform
but like unless you're recording video
you might as well be in the Stone Age
which makes no sense literally it makes
no sense but anyway anyway we have chit
chatted long enough I want to get your
takes on a lot of Pop Culture news yes
and we also have some Bravo news I want
to share with you so without further Ado
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know today's episode is
brought to you by Caraway get a head
start on spring cleaning with Caraway
their thoughtfully designed sets and
complimentary storage makes getting and
staying organized easier than ever so
you guys know that we have been obsessed
with caraway's pans for many many years
now and we just got their food storage
and if you just have a drawer full of
like empty Lids misplaced containers
check out their food storage solutions
they are so organized they're so
fabulous and just like everything at
Caraway they're premium and you can now
save 10 off on the full Suite of Caraway
products from their internet famous
cookware to their newly launched food
storage set their high quality ceramic
coated kitchenware is free of PTFE like
Teflon lead cadmium other toxic
materials Carol way kitchenware comes in
a variety of chic Shades and all their
sets include complementary easy access
storage solutions their Ceramics
naturally slick surface means minimal
oil or butter for slide off the pan eggs
and easy cleaning so again they're
non-toxic they're easy cooking that
slide off the pan that is real because I
have a husband who uses a pan and
doesn't immediately wash it and put it
in the dishwasher so hours later when I
come home normally if I'm not using a
Caraway pan I gotta really get in there
scrub use that elbow Caraway so easy
easy cleaning easy cooking easy
everything they're also really well
loved over 40 000 people have raved
about it visit carawayhome.com toast10
to take advantage of this limited time
offer for 10 off your next purchase the
deal is exclusive for toasters so visit
carawayhome.com toast10 or just use code
toast 10 at checkout non-toxic cookware
made Modern thanks Caraway today's
episode is also brought to you by
Sundays something for the stress bro in
your life so Sundays is healthy it is
air dried dog food made from a short
list of human grade ingredients Sundays
was co-founded by Dr Tory who's a
practicing veterinarian they they
contain a 90 Meat 10 vegetables and zero
percent synthetic nutrients so besides
USDA beef and all natural chicken you
will find digestive AIDS like pumpkin
and ginger and other disease fighting
antioxidants so dog parents have
reported a lot of benefits like fresher
breath softer fur better poops more
energy and as somebody who has a stress
bro in their life who has had breath
that is so toxic it could kill a person
it could burn the eyebrows off your face
Theo has had a huge impact in his breath
when I switched to Sundays I can
honestly say it has changed our
relationship I'm so grateful I'm very
breath conscious and Theo's breath for a
while was just like it was not going to
work for me so Sunday was a huge
Improvement there
um Sundays is also great because at a
zero prep zero mess and zero stress
unlike other fresh dog food it's shelf
stable which makes it easy to feed your
pup top quality food and every order
ships right to your door it's also 40
less expensive than other Healthy dog
foods because Sundays doesn't waste
money shipping Frozen packages we worked
out a special deal for our dog loving
listeners get 35 off your first order of
Sundays go to sundays4dogs.com toast or
use code toast at checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash toast upgrade your pup to Sundays
and feel good about the food you feed
your dog
story is little child bride news Millie
Bobby Brown who is 19 has announced her
engagement to Jake bongiovi so just call
her Millie Bobby bride page six always
has to be like salad Millie Bobby Brown
who's 19 announced her and Jake Bon
Jovi's engagement via Instagram on
Tuesday she wrote I've loved you three
Summers now honey I want them all we
love a Taylor Swift lyric The Stranger
Things actress captioned a black and
white photo her engagement ring could be
seen in the social media upload as Bon
Jovi who's 20 hugged her from behind the
beach so I think there's a lot to unpack
here the first being you know the nepo
baby of it all and wait is this Bon
Jovi's younger I think youngest what
you're saying Bon gov that's how it is
his literal it's are they adding an eye
somewhere his name is
b-o-n-g-i-o-v-i it's like they're
Italian but I think for his you know
like a All-American band he was Bon Jovi
I know the older brother is in like
Hampton water yes and he's Jesse Bon
Jovi okay uh are you from Sicily what is
going on I'm sorry uh I'm just like
friends with the Bon Jovi's maybe that's
why I knew that so were they dating for
three years or she just wanted to do a
Taylor Swift we've been together for a
while so I'm assuming it was accurate
how old was he 20 and she's 19. so you
do the math at least they're um like
somewhat age-appropriate for a
relationship it's not like people have
been like weirdly sexualizing Millie
Bobby Brown like since she was 12 like
it's really bizarre yeah so at least
she's eating someone her own age but it
is really young I mean I got married
young but I wasn't 21 when I got engaged
yeah she can't even drink at her wedding
unless you get married you know in the
Bahamas I do think sometimes with really
really famous people once you find
someone you feel safe with you almost
want to like stop the BS yeah
um
do I see
like well I didn't even know they were
dating well also about what you're gonna
say about famous people that I feel like
is true is Millie Bobby Brown at 19 is
not the same maturity level as you know
uh set 19 yeah she's probably seen and
lived a lot of more you know maturing
experiences it's still very young but I
would say she's probably as the
emotional intelligence and the life
experience of maybe like a 22 year old
I don't know honestly like an elephant
like a young elephant which are very
smart but like you wouldn't like trust
with your taxes right I Paige was
telling me yesterday that Millie Bobby
Brown has this like weird friendship
with Drake yes that's exactly what I'm
trying I wonder how Drake is feeling
right like it's but that like the height
of their really kind of weird friendship
was when she was like 15. yeah there's
just like and you know what I just last
night I watched Pretty Baby Brooke
Shields yes I have thoughts and so much
of what they were talking about like
weird things that went on when she was a
child really reminded me a lot of Millie
Bobby Brown it's gotten better now but
because she's older yes but when she
first popped on the scene people were so
[__] weird about her yeah she was so
young and she was like so like
romanticized and like borderline
sexualized and the Brooke Shields
documentary was chilling chilling I also
think that when people are British they
just sound really mature that's true
like if a two-year-old is like can I
have some water you're like are you sure
writing a thesis right yeah
but pretty baby was very interesting to
me me too
um the the craziest parts were her you
know cold calling out Michael Jackson
Tom Cruise and Andre Agassi
you're a tennis girly I mean I I think
that she basically said I went from one
controlling relationship with my mom to
a controlling relationship with Agassi
she sucked Joey's finger on friends yeah
and then Andre Agassi broke all his
trophies because he was so mad that was
like she could have politically been
like
he got jealous sometimes and it was hard
for her careers like that was a choice
yep but also in the tennis community she
got a lot of hate because when he
married her he did not win a tennis
match like the whole marriage so maybe
it was a little dig back at him because
people said she was really bad luck and
the second he married Steffi Graf he
started winning he started winning and
the crazy okay this is just ESPN sports
podcast now but she Brooke Shields had a
photo of Steffi Graf on her fridge
saying with because she loved her legs
these have athletic legs as inspo but
she manifested wrong and her husband
ended up marrying that woman imagine
because it's his fridge too
[Music]
he had to eat he was eating ice cream
every night too right so that's so
interesting just two cents on that the
Michael Jackson part for me was the most
wild Revelation because you know the
whole time I'm watching this documentary
and I never really thought a lot about
Brooke Shields I'm just like yeah she's
Brook Shields but I just found myself
like immediately having a lot of respect
for her she's extremely smart the whole
Yale or Princeton thing and then she
started talking about Michael Jackson
and the the people now reading the
documentary were like you know I never
thought they were dating and I'm like
there's no way
there's no way she would date Michael
Jackson like he's a freak and this whole
time I've just felt like she's so smart
she's so ahead of her time she didn't
get caught up in the whole Hollywood and
I'm like there's no way you're dating
[__] Michael Jackson well like she
has that innocence to her well it made
sense why he wanted to date her because
she was very stunted in a lot of ways
and he's a [__] freak and I was like
about to be so disappointed I'm like no
Brooke no and she's like we never dated
he told everyone we were dating and he
just wanted to adopt a child with me
like what a [__] freak and he's going
on Barbara Walters being like well right
now I'm dating Brooke Shields and she
calls him and she's like what the [__]
dude they were never dating it was crazy
that it was all PR and it makes you
question like for example the way that
Taylor Swift we've never seen her with
Joe when you see these other couples
everywhere and it's like oh they just
keep finding us they're not finding you
that's what she said we would go to
dinner and be like how did they find us
exactly I heard that with um Cheryl Crow
too she used to be a background singer
and she said there were always tabloids
saying that she was hooking up with
Michael Jack X and so he was working
full time well I think he wanted to
deflect from what other people were
saying about him which was that he was
romantically interested in minors I mean
it's a theme it's a theme I'm sensing a
theme it's a theme and I talked about it
on my part I said Paige we cannot keep
talking about this I know but the thing
about Michael Jackson is like people
still Revere him and like regard him as
like the King of Pop yeah um and for me
like he will always be the man who liked
minors and I'm that's that's all I'm
gonna see him as it's definitely tainted
yeah and not the good kind of tame right
I was like glad that she actually did
not date him I mean that was I kind of
love that she spoke up about that yeah
my only pet peeve with the documentary
was there's that link point where she
never like fully acknowledges that it's
like good to be pretty
you know it was like the pretty
privilege could have been just like
referenced yes because like I mean I'm
best friends with Paige like I see it
every day I'm a beautiful model like I
know that you wouldn't get it it is
burdensome to be that beautiful I get it
I get it but to not acknowledge how like
let's be honest she was homeschooled
like I don't know how she got into
Princeton but she kind of was like I got
it in the mail that I got into Princeton
and I'm you were also like the biggest
star in the world like that's why so it
it was so [__] up how like she was
doing nude scenes as a child but also
there there could be some reference of
like how being this beautiful helped you
a lot of Princeton because I mean think
about it when you pretty privilege is so
real when you make eye contact with
someone in the street and they're good
looking and they look at you you're like
I'm validated I am gorgeous sign me up
Willamina models when an ugly person
looks at you in the street what do you
do I have to flee town
[Music]
I'm being stalked and harassed
if I'm being honest pretty or ugly if
you look at me like I'm so self-centered
I'm like they're looking at me they're
probably a toaster they probably love my
Tick Tock my favorite do you ever have
those ghost sounds where you think
people are saying your name oh yeah and
especially because my name ends in uh
yeah just like every name Jessica yeah
every name Olivia when I was growing up
we never knew if we were someone was
shouting for Olivia or Claudia it's kind
of like a really kind of common syllable
my favorite is when people come up to me
and they just need directions and I'm
like do you wanna no I know I know
that's happened to me too and then or
they're just talking to you and you're
like this person does no idea who I am
but I thought that I was like getting
noticed yeah
um so anyway Brooke Shields it's very
interesting it is it is hard to be that
beautiful but let's be honest as a child
she was so strikingly so beautiful oh my
God it was like and I I know people were
obsessed with her as like an 11 year old
which was so weird how she like played a
prostitute and there were nude scenes
and she kissed this old man it was so
disgusting but I think she like when she
was in college or maybe a little bit
right before college she was so like to
me that's like the Brook Shields era
like when they had the doll of her like
yeah she's so beautiful my mom like is a
similar age as book Shields and she
talks about how it really negatively
affect affected women at the time that
prepubescent girls were being used as
models because my mom said when she got
boobs she was like upset because she was
like I don't want to have boobs I want
to look like Cindy Crawford which is
like no curves so it's so funny how
beauty standards are so Trend setting
they are and I will say I know there's a
lot of um like discourse around how the
Kardashians have negatively affected
body image but I do want to say I feel
like they really popularized they didn't
invent it but they popularized like
curves and big tits and now it's like
cool to be curvy and they had a lot to
do with that whereas like you know
heroin Chic was the the norm before the
Kardashians took over like fashion and
Beauty so say what you want but I do
think in a positive way they've impacted
the body the body like image about
beauty standards yeah white girls love
anorexia yeah and I they were like they
changed it like they really did thanks
face two thanks girl
um so Millie Bobby Brown is gonna be a
child bride I wonder how long they'll
wait to get married like if she'll have
a long engagement so she can drink at
her wedding like that's what I'm really
concerned about can I have like a glass
of champagne I want to know if Drake's
gonna be at the wedding I know I want to
know if Drake's gonna have a song come
out no I think Drake might be like you
know I object Drake is one of those guys
when it's like who are who are you into
I know and he doesn't really like I hate
celebs because honestly I think he's
scarred from Rihanna who like he was so
obsessed with and she was like get away
from me freak like I'm not interested
well they say that guy's biggest fear is
like being rejected and he was rejected
so publicly like on stage now he just
like follows around basketball players
and like takes selfies is I know but
like he's Jewish like I'm obsessed like
I would is he Jewish yes wow he doesn't
really talk about it which is like kind
of annoying but we know we know he
should so talk about it I know the last
Jewish rapper was like Matisyahu I know
and it's like that's all we are like
Dave
I don't think he's Jewish I just think
he's curly hair when are you dropping a
rap song
because we're waiting I know you're
basically the Rihanna of podcasting I
agree
um honestly my second song like wasn't
as big as my first my first was like
such a hit is that from streams on
Spotify like streams and everything and
there was just like less Fanfare and I
don't know I feel like people like were
over it if I'm being if I'm gonna be
vulnerable that's the story that you're
telling yourself maybe you're right and
you
you're right and but I do think that we
need a bob for the summer we need a Bob
I am working now on releasing my next
special and like that's my project and
hopefully it'll be out by summer
um where'd you film it or where you can
Gramercy theater I filmed it already
that's where like everyone yeah the big
time it was fabulous like we like it's
small and intimate so like it was really
I think I we when we did pre-sale on
patreon like it sold out so it was just
patreon like real toasters like real
girly girls the energy was amazing it
was on point we did two nights and
because it's so small like we built a
whole last stage and it was so cool
looking like I had this like little
thing that jetted out I felt like a pop
star I'm obsessed with you thank you was
your outfit good very good I can't wait
yeah um all right next story speaking of
the Kardashians Kim Kardashian was
announced yesterday as one of the stars
of American Horror Story season 12 and
like we're all confused I think she's
rebranding yeah I don't understand so
her and Emma Roberts released this like
trailer it didn't have any footage it
just was like five words and it took
literally 45 seconds for the words to
make a sentence it was so frustrating
but then you couldn't even see the full
Kardashian if it was so annoying for the
message of the trailer was that Emma
Roberts and Kim Kardashian are starring
in the next season of American Horror
Story has she acted in anything well she
did have that iconic scene in 90210 I
don't know I don't know if you remember
from high school where her and Chloe are
like trying to sell dresses to Naomi the
cool girl and then Naomi calls her a hoe
and they storm out it was really well
let's be honest keeping up the
Kardashians is a full question
oh great oh great she has plenty of
experience pretending pretend you don't
hate all your assistants right every day
pretend you like actually want to be
filming the show
so I would say yes she is experienced
I I do I loved Lady Gaga and but like
Lady Gaga is an artist like Lady Gaga
can do anything and that was the
beginning then now she's been nominated
for Oscars yeah that was like her first
Ryan Murphy saw something in her maybe
Ryan Murphy but again yeah we are not
out here telling women not to chase
their dreams
but Kim I think she loves to challenge
herself she does and I'm proud of her
for that yeah I just it comes to a point
it's kind of it's giving me like JLo
Vibes where when I'm that rich and
successful if I'm still like chasing
this hard
it's sad yeah I'm glad you brought up
JLo because JLo's had an interesting
point where she's like a singer and
she's like a an iconic singer and an
iconic actress and I know now any movie
that she puts out now or any song that
she puts out now is going to be bad it's
so weird how like she's this like and I
saw her she's one of the most talented
people in the world and everything she
does sucks
even her JLo Beauty like sucks what is
that like it's like she's a she's like a
legend who can't get arrested everything
she does is bad I don't understand well
the hustlers movie was like her moment
that come back and then but she did get
jipped on a lot of awards she did you
know she's very insecure that like
people say she's not a good actor and
all this stuff and she's well sorry
I watched her documentary and she's very
upset about it how do you know no I
watch I watch everyone's talking she so
badly wants to be taken seriously as so
many that's what it is she goes to sleep
at night the story she's telling in her
head we have a theme is that like yeah
people aren't respecting me
go to Wyoming not nearly Kanye but like
somewhere else like have a farm
occasionally have a script you look at
like that's what I want for her not like
Ben we gotta go outside get your nice
trench coat not that trench coat the
other one yeah get a Dunkin Donuts do
something stupid I'll call you she's
kind of playing the games like somebody
on the up and up would be playing
exactly she doesn't act like a legend
and she is like I saw her concert in the
2018 Super Bowl it was like a Super Bowl
party and she performed and it was like
Greatest Hits and you really do forget
how many Let's Get Loud like getting
rides on kicking getting ready
so good and she really could be like um
like a share like she could be Pat she's
definitely passed her prime but I feel
like she won't accept that I think the
olive oil Saga really hurt her it was
olive oil she basically was like I don't
do anything to my face I just use olive
oil and as an Italian who's just greasy
with olive oil all the time
that your face does not look like that
and then she came up with JLo Beauty
well it's like if you're only using um
olive oil why the [__] should we use
your products that seems I'm using Evo
from Rachel Ray but yeah there's
sometimes less is more in this industry
which me and you it's hard because we're
Workaholics but sometimes like even like
overexposure over saturation trying too
hard people are like we get it you want
to be famous yeah and it's a thin line
also once people like your stuff then
people offer you a lot of money to do
more stuff and you have to be selective
saying no is actually super powerful and
I'm working on it no you're so right
especially for somebody at JLo's level
like you have to be so particular every
like and that's why I feel like Lady
Gaga is really good at it she doesn't do
a lot and it takes years for her to do
something she'll be filming this Joker
movie for a while and then she'll be
doing the Joker thing for a few years
like the Oscars and she has these like
eras almost and it's really powerful and
she stays relevant but she doesn't feel
Overexposed I also thought in the past
that saying no people would just think
I'm a [__] but as I've been doing it
more often people like let's respect you
more and that was a really powerful
turning point for me because I also went
opportunist like I feel like worse I
feel like I got where I am because I
work hard so if saying no to
Opportunities means I'm not working hard
then I'm not going to be successful but
there's a way of like prioritizing your
mental health
um wow we are therapizing today no we're
kind of like giving doing the most we're
like [__] brene Browns so Kim
Kardashian is starting an American
Horror Story I've actually never seen
American Horror Story I'm not going to
watch it
um do you not like scary stuff
it's something well yeah I don't I don't
like I feel like a lot of people's like
personality is like I love horror like
let's go chill in the cemetery
um that's not me at all and so that's
not my genre of choice but also is there
a musical theater in American Horror
Story you know it's like I loved Glee a
Ryan Murphy production probably Ryan
Murphy's best work in my opinion did you
watch the Glee documentary no I didn't
because I actually saw a bunch of Glee
actual castmates say they weren't
approached or if they were they didn't
want to be a part of it and so like
these experts on set it was like you
know people in charge of hair wardrobe
yes and you know that person doesn't
really know what's going on it was a
thirsty piece of work it was a reach and
they were saying all these like a
Legends and I just felt afterwards a
little dirty and I read a review of it
because I was thinking about watching it
and I saw that like one of the takeaways
was that you know a lot of what went on
on the show um they blamed Leah Michelle
for like they very subtly tried to blame
Lea Michele for Cory Monteith's overdose
and how she was like the one pushing him
into drinking so honestly because I Stan
Lee Michelle to the day I die that's my
time pretty funny girl of course I
haven't saw it night number two oh my
God tonight number one
we're so mad about it I have to see it
I know I have to it's a really
real experience I hope she like resigns
and keeps going it's incredible I'm so I
was into the drama too I lived for every
minute and I'm sorry Beanie was never
right for that role and they went out of
their way to not give the original role
to Leah Michelle and you know what the
show they got is the show they deserved
yes because she had like a little bit of
a scandal you know they called her a
bully so you know what okay don't hire
her look what happened I do know her
stylist or at one point a stylist of her
not to name names and he said she's
lovely no and I'm sure at a time just
because people can't read does not mean
you have to bully them or call them
bullies no I have to say I'm sure at a
time she was a misery
like she blew up on this show and she
was the star of the show yeah and I'm
sure she was a diva I'm sure she was
rude too so that show is insane when you
weren't acting you had to be learning
music
like it was they said it was child labor
you know and I'm sure she was the devil
I'm sure okay people can change she was
literally 18. true like I don't care
true all right next door are you ready
oh this uh I feel like you're personally
invested in and I want to hear your dog
Tasha Adams is holding hands with Summer
House star Luke goldbrinson gold Brunson
amid dating rumors so the former
Bachelorette Tasha Adams Queen and
summer house Alum Luke are fueling I'm
not pronouncing his last name again Luke
are feeling our fueling romance rumors
after they were spotted getting cozy at
an Easter Sunday celebration in a since
deleted picture shared via Instagram by
Lindsay
um Luke could be seen standing behind
Tasha holding her hand the duo has
sparked dating speculation over the last
few weeks they posed for a group photo
alongside Carl Lindsay and like a bunch
of other people uh I've never met
so they're dating and you used to date
this man correct I mean data is a strong
word it was a hooking up it was no oh
okay it was a situationship situation do
you know Tasha I've met her briefly I
actually I did not know this oh breaking
news I saw this yesterday that's
exciting I hope that he finds love yeah
um I hope they all find love I mean
Tasha's a queen yes she's amazing I I
think I watched her season I actually
know her ex jpj
so she she likes the blonde she does man
go for it girl so now I'm thinking
because I ran into Tasha like a week ago
no maybe I have no like concept of time
maybe it was two weeks ago and she was
with a guy
and I was like oh that must be teacher's
new man
but what I have noticed if it was that
guy Luke from summer house I wasn't
really like invested I never really like
got super deep into summer house I can't
lie I mean neither I do know I do think
that it's like New York City people are
seeing each other and also like when
you're on reality TV and you see someone
else on reality TV
there's a lot of like common
commonalities yeah and then it's like we
take a photo people are gonna talk about
us I get it was just dating Ashley
though from Real Housewives of Potomac
he's kind of like making the route
today's episode is brought to you by Air
Doctor clean air is one of the fastest
and easiest ways we can have a positive
impact on our health you can improve the
quality of your indoor air with a high
quality air purifier and all you have to
do is breathe I'm not gonna lie I was a
little skeptical about air purifiers
until I got an air doctor in the studio
I'm literally looking at it right now
and one at home Ben has been always been
really into air purifiers and I was like
yeah sure there is such a huge
difference and when you think about it
it actually really makes sense because
indoor air can be two to five times more
polluted than outdoor air indoor air can
contain a variety of allergens like dust
of course pollen if you have a pet
there's pet dander and mold so that's
why you got to check out Air Doctor
you're breathing 20 000 times a day air
doctor is filtering out dangerous
contaminants and allergens so that your
lungs don't have to air doctor uses an
ultra HEPA filter that's been
independently tested to remove 99 of
testated bacteria and viruses so
everybody doctor captures a wide range
of pollutants including odors gases and
chemicals like formaldehyde from sticky
stinky gym clothes to chemical cleaning
products Air Doctor is always on call to
keep your air fresh and clean and it's
nice you don't have to do anything you
just leave it and it does all the work
for you and for me what's a better
product than something that does
everything for you and makes your life
better so bringing Air Doctor into the
podcast Studio has had a huge impact you
know our voices sound really great
because we're not all stuffed up we're
doing it for you guys an air doctor
comes with a no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee so if you don't
love it just send it back for a refund
mine is shipping head to
airdoctorpro.com use the promo code
toast and depending on the model you'll
receive up to 35 off that's up to 35 off
but only when you go to Air
Doctor pro.com promo code toast today's
episode is brought to you by a brand new
sponsor that we're really jazzed about
it's kiwico they are defining the future
of play by making it engaging enriching
and seriously fun they create super cool
Hands-On projects designed to create a
lifelong love of learning for kids each
month kiwico delivers crates packed with
fun and Sparks creativity with
kid-friendly topics and activities so
from engineering robots to learning
about the science of cooking that
interesting topics for every kid and
real hands-on experience to explore I
have to say this is just genius because
what I've learned as you know a very
involved Auntie is these kids oh my God
it's so hard to keep them engaged and
wanting you know fun stuff to do it's
exhausting and the older they get really
the more Curious they get so kibiko is
perfect it really is you're getting
Hands-On science art and geography
projects delivered to your door every
month and that you know as an auntie
myself it really is hard to find
creative ways to keep your children busy
challenged and off the iPad you know
sometimes it's just that's all they want
so cultivate your child's natural
creativity and curiosity with new
Hands-On projects every month and you're
encouraging your kids to be innovators
and creative thinkers and watch their
confidence grow as big as their smile
they won't believe what they can build
and accomplish with kibiko the moment of
Pride and accomplishment at the end of a
kiwico Project Sparks creative
confidence for ongoing thinking and
experimentation now let me say kiwico
has saved my life on on many many days
especially when I was in Florida last
week these kids you guys they just they
need to be stimulated and sometimes me
singing and dancing as much as it pains
me to say is not enough redefine
learning with play explore Hands-On
projects that build creative confidence
and problem-solving skills with kiwico
get 50 off your first month plus free
shipping on any crate line at kiwico.com
toast that's 50 off your first month at
k-i-w-i-c-o.com slash toast I think a
lot of our Mamas and aunties are gonna
really appreciate this new sponsor enjoy
um okay so but now I just want to ask
you about summer house I don't know if
you're seeing any of the discourse on um
like this season of Summer House how
it's like for [__] do you know anything
about it I'm literally so removed by it
but pages will tell me things I need to
know okay or things that will make me
laugh well what's going on now is kind
of like the the comeuppance I think for
a lot of the cast it's like finally
Lindsay's getting what Lindsay deserves
and I've from the seasons that I've
watched in the past like Lindsay has
definitely been the villain in my eyes
and she's never really gotten her
like it hasn't she's never gotten like
called out and she's getting called out
this season and I don't really feel like
she's done anything wrong this season if
anything this is the most kind of stable
she's been and I don't understand why
now it's like you know we're all coming
for Lindsay but it's like we probably
should have come for her a few years ago
yeah I know that like there's a lot of
people bringing up stuff from the past
presents and stuff but I'm like aren't
we in a new season yeah like let's get
some new fun drums so we know that you
and Paige are obviously besties so yeah
who do you have a relationship with I'm
Sierra I'm very close with Sierra like
we talk all the time cat memes all the
time it's probably tough to be like
friends with someone who's so beautiful
honestly it's it's a thing where I'm
like it keeps me grounded it keeps me
humble and now she's a Victoria Secret
model do you think it's getting to her
head or she's still right I think it's
like where she needs to be like I know
she was saving lives as a nurse and I
felt bad being like you should be in a
Maybelline commercial but like save
lives whatever is good for you yeah it's
just like leave some room for the rest
of us yeah
um but she's also people don't know is
like she's so funny and Goofy and silly
so when you're with her she doesn't give
the energy of like I know I'm hotter
than you even though she does because
she is but she doesn't like put it in
your face like Brooke Shields oh
my God I love Brooke Shields she's an
icon
um but yeah so I'm also
um friends with Maya oh you are yeah we
haven't like hung out a lot but like
we've whenever we see each other it's
really cool and that's it
yeah I mean but I have no animosity
towards anyone I was just gonna say like
do you hold any Hate in Your Heart for
like Kyle
no that was a long hesitation no I mean
I actually have done like a lot of work
in therapy where like if you hold on to
stuff it just messes with you it's like
honestly Kyle and I were cool for so
long yeah and we got along for so long
and like so I don't really remember like
the last little book okay I have I'm
kind of like Kyle choosing to remember
the guy and Kyle and I are both like big
personalities you put people on reality
TV yeah it's really a reality TV drama
that happened like in my when I think
about the friendships I'm like yeah if
we weren't on a reality TV show that
Dynamic would never have happened that's
true and Amanda and I actually have
texted like we have no animosity towards
each other okay good good good yeah and
Kyle was the one who
motivated you or inspired you maybe to
name your podcast giggly Squad right yes
yeah do you think that kills him
I think that he should feel honored yeah
I mean you guys are just like we love
like a collab being successful selling
out big theaters I did the podcast tour
he knew that Paige and I like to giggle
a lot and it annoyed him but what what's
something sometimes people hate can make
someone love yeah
um but shout out to all the giggly
girlies that's right
um okay next up we've got some shocking
Royal news Kate Middleton has broken a
royal Rule and has shamed the entire
family
yeah everyone is seeing red because
Princess Kate Middleton was spotted
sporting a crimson colored nail polish
as she stepped out for church service on
Easter Sunday
she was pictured looking perfect in
royal blue but the Beauty's contrasting
red tipped fingers perturbed many
royalists as it's been widely reported
that the late Queen Elizabeth II
disapproved of bright nail polish
according to multiple Outlets the queen
stuck to one light pink color named by
Essie ballet slippers and expected other
Royal women to do the same some on
social media claimed that Kate didn't
exactly nail it with one writing too bad
the whole royal family photo op is
ruined by Kate's Brazen red nail polish
it's not protocol and Kate Middleton has
shamed the entire family
disgusting another raged Meghan Markle
was slaughtered for breaking protocol
just for wearing a nail polish that
wasn't pink now here is Kate Middleton
wearing red nail polish who will Who
will we be told how bold and daring she
is now I want to say this is moronic
Beyond Next Level moronic
um Meghan Markle should be allowed to
wear red nail polish as should Kate
Middleton I will say at least Kate
waited for Queenie to die yeah to whip
out the red nail polish see I think she
should be canceled yeah I think we
should do her old tweets yeah and I
think she should be stoned and I think
that like it's a start I mean what else
more horrible things could she be doing
if she's wearing red nail polish also
like clearly she's a [__] yeah clearly
she doesn't support women
and specifically older women in comedy
her she's probably in with Jen Shaw yeah
and I think do based on these photos
she's a homophobe
and I think that the you know
ADL should get involved because this
feels anti-Semitic
and I'm upset she's definitely like
you know what I'm disappointed Kate do
better
have we asked her about abortion rights
yet right no I mean maybe or is she
saying something about gun laws no I
think there's something there with the
red maybe this is her speaking to us you
know she's she's Limited in what she can
say they're not political so maybe it's
a cry for help maybe she's telling us
something maybe the red is maybe she's a
Republican
or maybe
or I don't know what red could simply
maybe she likes the blood of children
maybe it's a statement on the Dalai Lama
oh he's always wearing that red
or maybe
she's letting everyone know that her
favorite Spritz is grapefruit
she is a grateful girly that's probably
it yeah if we had to let's be
conservative like that's what she's yeah
we don't want to like reach yeah we want
to be radical no that's great because
she's a grapefruit girly but all you
know I'm not listening to her anymore
yeah not that she spoke I'm so
disappointed I'm so just I used to like
her too I used to like it I used to like
her but nail polish now I see her I see
a new side of her
and I find it disgraceful
and honestly anti-patriotic but her
husband could do nothing wrong King
literally Future King how no one no one
talked about his nails so true he
probably has like crusty cutically like
he's definitely not fingering her
do the Royals finger each other
you know what the Royals don't make eye
contact when they have sex I am actually
in not to speak for Jackie and I but
Jackie and I we are monarchists like we
love the crown we love the royal family
yes
um so I'm just gonna choose I gotta
respect not to talk about her vagina
okay so you don't support
um free sexuality and other women in the
Royals agreed
well
good point yeah are you disappointed I
mean I look at me differently I feel
like I need to give you an apology for
even asking you that no no no no you're
fine okay let me know if you need one I
have the dumbest Fifth and final story
because it was a slow day but I feel
like I would like your thoughts the FBI
is warning the public against using
those public phone charging stations so
the FBI is warning consumers about juice
jacking where Bad actors are using
public Chargers to infect phones with
malware so the law enforcement agency
says consumers should avoid using public
chargers at malls and airports and stick
to their own USB cables and charging
plugs
so avoid using the free chart they
tweeted avoid using the free charging CR
stations in airports hotels or shopping
centers people have figured out a way to
use public USB ports so not even the
Chargers they're saying don't use public
USB ports you know how like at the
airport they have outlets and USB and
it's always like emergency mode when you
need to use it but they're saying do not
use it because you can introduce malware
and monitoring software onto your device
carry your own charger and USB cord and
use an electrical outlet instead who is
malware what is a malware that's such a
good question because like as the IT
department so it's my understanding
based on my you know limited knowledge
that malware is basically like viruses
I feel like it's 2023 like how is my
phone still getting a virus I know and
to me like the virus thing sounds like a
little bit of a conspiracy theory but
having like freaks monitor you like that
I could see happening like people
hacking into USB ports they can monitor
like young girls phones but I do have to
say I love attention
I want people to be watching and be like
oh that Tick Tock video did do well oh
she's so quirky
oh um she is you know checking your
email she's at zero she's not like other
girls she's not like other girls a lot
of cat videos yeah we could do without
what would like a hacker find on your
phone for me they would find like some
of the most like vile [__] talking like
I when I'm like feeling like a safe
space and I'm like talking [__] with
like my sisters I say some of them are
you a voice note girl no I put that [__]
in writing I am so [__] evil I say
the meanest [__] like I say what's
really on my mind like I want it on
record
Paige and I will voice note for like an
hour and my mom was visiting the other
week and she was like [__] call her
yeah no no it's an art well that's the
other thing I don't actually text that
much everything I do is FaceTime uh I'm
such a FaceTime girl and then you get to
look at yourself too during it like
you're like you're starring in a movie I
actually have like a phone stand next to
my bed so I can put my face time
resting sometimes like hold it up yeah
and you don't want to get like a kink in
your neck what would we find on your
phone I am like so obvious like in my
explore page it's like how to go viral
no it's like tennis jokes like I watched
tennis tutorials tutorials that's what
Ben does for golf that's not weird I'm
I'm like an old man deep I'm a retired
old man deep down yeah so tennis Strokes
um
stand-up comedy yeah and then like so
many animal videos it's insane I always
forget that you're like a cat girl I am
a cat girl which but I rescued a senior
pit bull before so I'm better than all
of you yeah you are um I'm gonna we're
gonna be in West Hampton this summer
we're gonna Foster some animals shout
out Southampton Animal Shelter you're
gonna be fostering cats or dogs dogs
unless there's like a bunch of kittens
because cats are more like you can't
really take them for a week yeah they're
like what is this yeah they don't trust
you I just like I feel like we're so
limited in where our friendship can go
because like I can never go over to your
house but I would not say hi to you
she'd be under the couch no I like I
wouldn't I actually would not step foot
in your house just because like are you
allergic no oh you just hate
um fluffy things that when you pet them
they vibrate which is adorable no I just
hate cats like it's
um like are we gonna really end on this
sour note No No Yeah and we have like a
lot of cat the meow toaster but I know I
love dogs you call them they call
themselves I love all animals which you
know cat people tend to like all animals
dog people come from cats you know I'm
very like Niche I don't love it but I do
would argue that a King Charles is kind
of like
oh my God don't insult myself that's how
you want to end the show you want to
insult my son
noted Hannah don't talk about my family
noted blood is thicker than water okay
disgusting oh my God have you had Teresa
on we have
we actually had Teresa on like many
moons we've had her recently but the
first time we had her was when back when
we were the morning breath we did a live
show and she was one of our guests and
then um we all went out to dinner
afterwards
um that was back in the days when Cheech
was working for Bravo and we all
coordinated this dinner and it was like
kind of surreal to be at dinner with
Trey
um her daughters weren't there which was
upsetting but I would have loved to have
seen her daughters and it was fabulous
like she's definitely exactly who she is
on TV exactly as she's in real life and
I know that famous story of her I worked
at benches when you worked at betches
she came into the office and she was
like oh my God girl with no job so what
happened is actually at batches because
I'm Italian I thought that I just knew
her last name and I called her I've seen
this video and she just goes why that's
not my name and then so we kind of she
was a great sport how did you pronounce
it
yeah I mean forever it was Teresa
Giudice and then like years years and
years later it came out like we were all
saying it wrong it's actually Juju yes
but now you you know the names Bon Jovi
but everyone still says judice like yeah
but I think Teresa Jude I think I say
judici now it was disrespectful of me it
was but we got over it but fast forward
I saw her on the street and she's waving
at me I'm waving back and she goes going
no job oh my God and I was like okay
she's singing Starlet and I was like oh
my God she thinks I'm skinny
obviously our dinner like didn't have
like that much of an impact on her we
went to the Bowery hotel we had a
delicious pasta at Gemma and she
couldn't even remember my face so that
feels good but that's like a true star I
heard she doesn't she doesn't watch any
episode and I think that's why she
survived reality TV there's actually
because I don't think she knows what's
going on and if she's the best she
doesn't get to win the weeds it's not
that serious but she still eats and
leaves no crumbs every single episode
she Still Remains the most toxic person
on reality television way worse than
genja yeah and not Kate Middleton but
yeah but I don't know those nails
[Laughter]
um well Hannah it's been such a delight
thank you so much for being here if you
guys just can't get enough of Hannah
make sure to follow her on tick tock not
that she needs any more followers maybe
you should follow me on Tick Tock um and
check out GS2 podcast one of course she
hosts with Paige from summer house it is
called family Squad and then she's her
own more interview based like more
serious a little bit more mental health
called burning in Hell burning spelled
b-e-r-n you are such a journalist I'm
also going to be at the West Hampton
theater this summer oh I did it's
literally so fun if the girls want to
come oh I know Long Island girl is yeah
we're toasters that they are so nice and
perfect size and they have good snacks
in the back okay noted no because like I
always get like my snacks you know
what's in your writer oh my God it's so
embarrassing it's like so many covering
free diet Pepsi Spritz of course
sparkling water Flat Water uh bottle of
tequila a [__] ton of lemons
bag of baked glaze bag of pretzels bag
of baked Ruffles and they always have a
hard time finding it when I'm in like
the middle of nowhere they're like baked
I'm like you don't know baked lays it's
so bizarre
um they're like late just scrambling
chicken fingers french fries grilled
chicken white rice and a Caesar salad
not for me that's amazing yeah and maybe
a grilled salmon for Ben I'm so bad with
writers oh my God I can't I can't get
enough free [__] or they'll get my right
or wrong and there was like a huge like
deli sandwich the other day and I was
like I didn't and they were like that
was in your writer and I was like oh my
team messed up sorry did you beat it
absolutely not oh I can't I'm not gonna
eat a full ham salami yeah provolone
cheese well I want to come to your show
you came to my show right yes at West
Hampton yes you got me tickets yes it
went in the back I said hi I'm gonna
need some tickets you're very busy I
also yeah I have a New York show in
Times Square I know it's Time Square
blah but on the 27th there's uh of April
of April I'm at Stagecoach
with all the bachelor people yeah oh my
God make out Blake no
oh you're not into Blade no first of all
I'm married I don't know
second of all I think like on a
personality level there's probably not
anyone on reality TV that I was like
more immediately put off by them like
and three he's dating giannina from Love
is Blind which is the funniest weirdest
thing of all time I've actually met him
and he's really nice he's really cool
but maybe not like not my time not not
good right enough for you to leave your
marriage no there's a few people I would
leave my husband for um
and he's not one of them
who'd you leave your husband for
um great question
and don't say nobody like Luanne my rose
is my husband
I'm like I'm so I mean I'm I'm so
obsessed with them it's really annoying
because we don't see each other a lot
but no but still you need to answer
Pedro Pascal on this is uh the The Last
of Us
very different okay that's a good one
mine's John Mayer
but I justify it by saying um actually
Ben looks a lot like John Mayer so you
would sit in a room well he just gets
inspired and starts playing the guitar
and like working working I mean just
think about it how I mean you haven't
seen them but my jugs are extremely
inspiring and I think he would write
like some beautiful songs about my body
oh like once he sees these tits It's
Over okay are you starting only fans is
this your drive Ben you know my husband
Ben has a podcast with Josh Peck yeah
it's so it's literally so good is so
personable he's so everything I'm
obsessed yeah and they had on the
episode that came out yesterday with
Tana Mojo and she's an only fans girl
and she actually started she has a
really cool business where she started
an agency where she represents other
only fans content creators and gets
himself she's a boss and promotes them
it's actually really smart women
supporting women and she said that if
Josh and Ben started like a non-nude
only fans like they could do a million
dollars in a month that's crazy because
I've highly I've been told that my foot
has a good Arch don't know what that
means let's see I mean
I mean I I didn't shave very well and I
do actually the cameras are not that
high quality okay good
um but
I think like foot modeling like if we
have to yeah you could do it anonymously
as a foot only fans person or like be
really non-anonymous with it oh yeah
blow it up yeah as seen on Bravo yeah
chat room for 42 episodes Hannah you are
a doll you are a delight thank you so
much for gracing us with your presence
thank you this went by so fast and I
love the toasters shout out to all of
them and shout out to the giggly
toasters make sure to follow Hannah
anywhere you can find her and go listen
to our podcast and go see her on tour
she's constantly on tour what is the
website for your tickets oh yeah Hannah
burner.com Boston Vegas Louisville Tempe
stuff coming up Tempe dark thank you
guys so much for listening to the just
Millennium Morning Show where we deliver
the best five stories YouTube everybody
Friday on YouTube for watching this on
YouTube please if you're describing the
video thumbs up also available podcast
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow in studio with
the snatchler Margot snitch is joining
us you don't want to miss it you don't
want to miss it bye